my last question for you is uh when you
guys were doing the filming for shark
tank i think you recently did that over
the last few months what's the
conversation behind closed doors uh you
mark lori barbara robert the whole crew
what are most people uh saying about
this are they all as bullish as you are
or there's still uh some skepticism uh
among that uh crowd and i use them as a
proxy for most of kind of uh uh the
average american that is one of their
biggest sources of kind of business
content is watching shark tank so what's
the thought process of
of your co-host
well you know we don't do crypto deals
on shark tank or marijuana i mean we
don't we can't do those for because
of regulatory reasons and we were also
very very sensitive to the regulator for
obvious reasons for you know it's a
network uh owned by disney etc
but behind closed doors um
mark and i are very very active in
crypto you know the cubit is uh we we
share notes on nfts
um
you know
i'm i'm intrigued by that whole uh
business and i'm very active in that
i've invested in uh wonderful
you know which is decentralized finance
um they're bringing their app in the
next few weeks the company just raised
another 20 million yesterday
also in jordan freed's business the
platform called immutable holdings he
owns nft.com he's setting up profiles
for most of the s p 500 brands i'm
working with him on the watch industry
for example i own a piece of that
company too
uh
and and you know i look at all these
i look at this stuff probably of the
sharks two uh two out of us
are are allocated
portfolios to it the others not so much
yet but they're very interested
they're more traditional in how they um
deploy capital but i don't know how you
ca how you can ignore it anymore
um given the pressures that you started
this conversation with around inflation
and you know decentralized finance the
productivity you can provide to the
economy
you just can't ignore it and i
understand the regulatory cloud i get it
but i don't think even the regulators
want to abandon the promise that crypto
has for the american economy
it just has to be the rules based and
they'll get there eventually even if it
takes time
that's where we're at so the sharks that
are not yet allocating is this basically
a question around regulatory or is it
they're not yet convinced or what is
kind of the biggest um critique or the
biggest obstacle that you see
turning them from uh not being allocated
to actually getting allocated
primarily regulatory i mean you know
without naming any specific shark they
all have big brands they all support all
kinds of companies some of them have
their own products goods and services
around their name
and it's it's the same reason that they
don't they don't get involved in the
cannabis market it's a schedule one
regulated narcotic in multiple states
and yet it's legal and others but
they they they have to be compliant and
so
any they all have advisors and
you know it's like i said earlier i have
to fight my auditors i have to say no no
no no you don't get it they say we get
it and the answer is no and so
it takes a fair amount of energy to
pursue this when all the advisors around
you are saying no and won't even support
you
i mean
that's
that's really
the truth about what what crypto is now
is it's a growing
it was a baby five years ago now it's a
teenager and it's nasty because it's not
stopping it's gonna keep going and it's
gonna be an adult soon and those teenage
years are a [ __ ] that's the problem
i know you well enough that all you need
to do is when you talk to the other
sharks say listen i believe in it so
much i got my own dough in it and when
you say that they'll obviously
understand that uh if you're
uncomfortable they should be they know
they know and everybody's interested to
see what my holdings are i get that
every day you know what i'm really
worried about i don't want to be one of
these guys
that you know gets some obscure token or
coin and promotes it and you know all
that stuff i don't want to be seen that
way i'm being very careful to make these
long-term investments because i believe
in you know the best way to look at this
and i i tell people this that really
grill me on crypto and particularly when
that you keep floating that video of us
together on cnbc you know on twitter and
i get abused over and over again i'm
never going to forgive you that i'm
going to figure a way to get you back i
don't know how i'm going to figure it
out but what i tell them is
look
do you invest in google do you invest in
microsoft those are big holdings for me
they are software companies when you
invest in crypto and the blockchain and
the level one level two ideas out there
and a lot of these tokens and a lot of
these shared ledgers you're investing in
software why would you invest in
microsoft and not in the chain
why
why wouldn't you and they said well i
never thought of it that way well think
about it that way because that's what it
is you're just adding to your software
productivity portfolio now i get it it's
controversial and all the rest of it but
the innovation that's occurring
by these developers the hottest hands on
the keyboard are now in crypto the
smartest guys
are doing this work and you're getting
engineers are leaving traditional
productivity software like crazy to go
into crypto whether it's a startup or
work with a behemoth or whatever it is
because the productivity
opportunities there are greater than
anything else we have in software and so
you know i just gave you the use case
for watches it's for every asset class
it's all coming but it's all software
so the politicians that say shadowy
super coders kevin says the hottest
hands are on the keyboard i like that
that's a much better way to put it i
think
yeah well i mean look politicians have
to make press
they're constantly raising capital for
their own campaigns i understand the
pressure they're under nothing gets you
more press
the two ways to get press these days is
beat up facebook which always works it
gets you on the hill which is ludicrous
because they're the backbone of small
business in america
and talk about crypto as being used for
crime that's going to get you a lot of
headlines that's going to help you raise
a lot of money it's never going to stop
but that's not what crypto's about
anymore decentralized finance is going
to be very disruptive very powerful very
productive it's going to eliminate a lot
of fees and it's going to make life a
lot easier for everybody like me when i
talked about trying to buy and sell
european stocks in multiple currencies
i mean why wouldn't i invest in that